اهي ابرز نقاط هذه الخطه خطه العمل
الجديده التي طرحتها المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لمواجهه الهجره المتصاعده في وسط البحر
المتوسط وما الذي ستغيره بالنسبه الى
الدول المغربيه
بعض الاطلاع على ال 20 نقطه التي وردت في
خطه العمل الاحظ ان هذه النقاط كان قد
قامت ترحها في السابق ولم يتم التوسل الى
اتفاق بشانها الان يوم الجمعه سيكون هناك
اجتماع لوزاره العدل والداخليه الاوروبيين
وسيفع هذه في حال التوصل الى الاتفاق
سيقدم هذه القطعه للمجلس الاوروبي للتبني
اياها اهم هذه النقاط هي التفاوض مع
العديد من الدول وخاصه مع دول شمال
افريقيا همم مصر تونس همم
والمغرب وايضا مع النيجر من اجل ان يتم
همم التعاون فيما مع دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
من ناحيه من اجل تحديد همم
ومساعده الدول على
مواجهه ومنع الهجره من حدود تلك الدول
الخاصه من ليبيا الى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
نقاط اخرى زياده التعاون استاذ والتجاري
والزراعي مع تلك الدول اا من اجل تحفيزها
على
وابقاء من اجل ان تبقي اللاجئين داخل
اراضيها والا تتركهم يذهبوا الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي نقاط اخرى ادفع زياده
التعاون بين
منظمه فرنتكس التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي
والتي هدفها حمايه الحدود الخارجيه دول
الاتحاد الاوروبيه التعاون هذه المنظمه مع
منظمات دوليه من اجل ايضا مكافحه الهجره
غير الشرعيه ونكتها هامه وهي ان الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي تريد الدول وذلك عن طريق
زياده عدد التاشيرات للاشخاص المهاجرين
بشكل شرعي ولكن حسب حاجه الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه نقاط اخرى اخرى
عديده زياده همم اعمال التنميه وايضا
تشجيع عوده اللاجئين والمهاجرين غير
الشرعيه الاراديه الى بلادهم الاصليه
قبولهم محاوله تفاوض مع دول اخرى من اجل
قبول هم قبول اللاجئين غير الشرعيه
والمهاجرين غير الشرعيه داخل الدول شمال
افريقيا وطبعا كل هذه الامور كانت قد تم
التحدث عنها في السابق ولكن لم يتم اا حتى
الان تنفيذها بشكل جدي معروف ان الهجره
غير الشرعيه ارتفعت من السته 50% همم هذا
العام الماضي هذا العام كانوا الناس نحو
90,000
همم مهاجر غير شرعي همم تم دخولهم الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك محاوله ارجعهم كل
هذه الامور الان يتم التحدث عنها ولكن كان
هناك ام في همم قبل عامين تقريبا كان قد
كان متبني ميثاق الهجره واللجوء الاتحاد
الاوروبي طبعا لم يتم تبني بشكل رسمي ولكن
الان هناك مطالبه باحياء او بتنفيذ هذا
همم هذا الميثاق يتعلق بالعديد من الامور
التي ذكرتها سابقا معروف انه خلال همم
المحاوله الاتحاد الاوروبي ووقف الهجره
القادمه من ليبيا كان قد تم التحدث عن
كثير من الاجراءات التي ذكرتها ولكن لم
يتم تنفيذ كما يجب حتى الان اشكرك كله
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد محمد رجاء بركات الخبير
في العلاقات الروبيه